[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
hey everybody welcome to episode 6 of
the 13 o'clock podcast today's show we
have kind of an interesting theme as our
brothers yeah
the weirdo bro show yeah sometimes you
know one weirdo in enough you're gonna
have to - weird I've got two cases of
two weirdos
yeah which have kind of similarities but
all you know well we'll just we'll get
to when we get to UM we'll get to it
okay yeah so what if we decide to first
we're gonna talk about the song but all
your brothers alright right so those of
you who are from New York or know
anything about New York history have
probably heard of the Collyer brothers
they're actually pretty famous yeah um
this was from the 1940s they actually I
think they actually died in the 1940s
they were born in 1881 one of them was
they weren't twins it was one of them
was like four years older yeah and um
their names were homer and Langley yeah
and they actually only got famous I mean
they were fairly normal up until they
got a little older well their dad was a
doctor when he yeah gynecologist Jonica
kind of ties in to our other case which
is kind of wicked right this is a story
I don't know if you guys are ever
watched a show hoarders all right we
have a love fascination with this with
with with yeah with the oddities that
are hoarders well these guys were
probably two of the we of the strangest
hoarders of all times and probably two
of the best hoarders well yeah in the
sense that yeah well do you have a
hoarder this is how this is how hardcore
their hoarding was to this day evidently
according to the internet yeah in New
York City and along the east coast
firefighting lingo they go to a hoarders
house it's still called a Colliers
mansion this is a Colliers mansion
situation they will say in firefighting
school and that's you know if any of you
fire firefighters let me know but that's
what I read online now this case is well
documented and on our youtube show
version of this one you can go in you
see photos we got lots of photo
there's lots of folks
and this is not normal hoarding this is
no this is next-level yeah if they
filled an entire what was a four-story
building a four-story brownstone right
up to the roof they couldn't get in
there yes once you tell the story Jenny
have this start
well basically like I said they were
both fairly um fairly normal I want to
say there were some kind of weird things
about them one was older than the other
I believe Homer was the older one I want
to say
uh yeah yeah Homer was the older one now
they came from a very prominent and old
New York family yeah they had money I
mean apparently um their family going
back generations had come on the second
boat like after the maid yeah these were
actually like Blue Blood snobs yeah yes
they were like uh you know upper-class
it kind of people so their dad was a um
was a gynecologist as I said I think
their mom was an opera singer or
something like that and I forgot what
their what were their jobs well actually
um one of them Homer was a well they
both went to I both did they both go to
Columbia I want to say it was it was a
pretty you know they were professionals
I don't lump ba yeah they went to
Columbia and if they were professionals
Homer had his degree in admiralty law he
was a lawyer that's right and Langley
studied chemistry and engineering and he
was also a concert pianist yeah who
performed at Carnegie Hall's guys
weren't dummies no um and like I said
their family was quite wealthy right and
they inherited their mom's mansion which
was a brownstone yeah what ended up
happening was yeah it was a huge
four-story brownstone and it was in uh
Harlem right which actually was a
upper-class area everybody in the early
1900s um so what happened they lived
there now here's a weird thing about the
two brothers though they never married
and they always lived with their parents
even when they were much older okay yeah
that may not have been all that unusual
yeah maybe it's weird back in the early
nineteen hundred's I think it was I
think it was I think they mostly lived
on
family estates until you got married
yeah you bet maybe rich people that's
how they were I think yeah but like I
said it now
their dad was also known as something of
an eccentric not too crazy but he would
do kind of wacky things so maybe genetic
I don't know but um so their dad left I
think at one point that died later and
then the mom died I think in the 20s
yeah 19 well the dad died in 1923 and
the mom died in 1929
yeah the exact dates don't really matter
yeah they were left there in the house
bottom yes so they had lived it with
their parents all their lives 1929 their
mother died left them the house and
everything in it all of their dad's
medical stuff right now for four years
after the mother died the brothers were
normal they still had jobs they still
went out they still associated live
shift yeah so it wasn't like it was
immediate or mom died when a depression
or anything like that what actually
caused it was Homer um start eagle
blonde started to go blind right and he
eventually ended up losing his eyesight
which you know kind of sucks and then so
after he went blind Langley was here
break quit his job yeah there because
I'm gonna have to put the vaping picture
yeah you need to take another vaping
picture Takia same one okay but um so
yeah homer web lined Langley quit his
job do you lay a stay there and take
care to take care of his brother right
now because at the time Harlem was
beginning to become the Harlem you know
diversify say well the and the crime
started going up like it wasn't you know
it was not becoming an upper class area
anymore so the Great Depression hit yeah
the Great Depression hit and all the
other wealthy people moved away right
and they were building a subway stop
right around there they were building
all these low-cost apartment buildings
and whatnot and so so the old guys
started dumbing they weren't super old
old not yeah yes I think yeah I think
they were in there they started wigging
out they thought they thought that
all the new people have moved into the
to the apartment or earned to the into
the air we're out to get him
yes they started developing paranoia and
evidently they did kind of cross crowds
because they were like the last of the
rich people in the area yeah and you
know this is depression-era and they
would sit there and they'd watch them
the teenagers would watch I'm trying to
give me a skills it's kind of ironic
because they kind of developed this kind
of an unfounded paranoia at first that
like everyone was out to get him and all
this other stuff but yeah real but then
because they acted so weird everyone
else in the neighborhood was curious
about that yeah they wanted to know
what's going on so you know kids would
come and like try and look in the
windows or like run walks through the
windows and stuff like that also rumors
circulated now now later on like like I
said Homer went blind and he also got
rheumatism later and became paralyzed so
he could no longer move and Langley had
to take care of everything for him yeah
um so so they both went in the how now
Langley still went out yeah but this
divided that this is let's get down to
the crux of the matter what happened was
is they decided to build a fortress of
junk and this is what they were going to
protect themselves with to keep people
from breaking into their brownstone
apartment that the one that could see
what was his name Langley was so nine
they wouldn't go out there and just get
any piece of furniture or books or
anything and bring it into the
brownstone and he started to make
defensive barriers booby traps booby
traps and barriers right yeah it ended
up the entire building all four stories
of that building was filled to the roof
on each floor and the only way to get
around was to go through a tree a system
of tunnels that was made through the
junk tunnels and booby traps and when
they would enter into the house he would
pull junk in behind him to make walls
and things we'd call I guess you'd call
Rock drops in other words falling traps
of debris I wasn't there something
electrical - there's all kinds of weird
stuff well I'm not sure about
that because at some point I mean like I
said after Homer also became paralyzed
um
Langley would only leave the house after
dark and he looked like a bomb like
everyone that lived around there like
all the stores he went into they said he
was a nice man but that he was obviously
crazy and he looked like a bomb yeah and
um but he would sometimes walk like way
over to some other neighborhood just get
a look for Brian he didn't like it miles
to get a loaf of bread that was a little
bit cheaper than the other places yeah
stuff a little you know bread yeah lived
in little nests inside the yeah that was
basically like the only areas cuz I mean
Homer couldn't move well I mean I'd
Langley condition I just ah I guess but
I think the trouble started when they
stopped paying the the electricity and
the telephone yeah and the gas and the
gas and then they stopped paying for
their mortgage yes and the police came
witness to reap well actually what ended
up happening first whatever happening
first was they had actually bought the
building across the street okay before
they went nuts okay they were going to
turn it into an apartment building
alright but they first stopped paying
the mortgage on that I think all right
so the police repossess it you know went
to repossess it and that's when they
started arguing with the police and all
this other [ __ ] and also I think I also
heard that a neighbor that was once like
looking in their windows or something
like that they bought that house like to
get rid of the thing these guys weren't
poor they were yeah which is weird now
because they weren't poor I mean
obviously they came from a very
prominent family
so rumors circulated in the neighborhood
that they were just sitting on big piles
of cash in there yes so actually people
did try to break in yeah so they weren't
wrong no they were trying to get in
there cuz they thought there was
treasures they thought there was stuff
in there right money or whatever now
like we said they did have money and
like I said after you know after they
died they found out but um but you know
they weren't sitting on piles of cash
and there was all in the back but the
rumors were that they were they were
sitting on piles of cash because they
didn't want to put it in the back
they were paranoid about bags it
actually was in the bag now when they
would when they came down and try to
repossess the place they actually tried
to bash through the front doors but of
course they just bashed into a wall of
stacked stuff yes
what was it books bottles uh pretty much
there was a whole car chassis in March
as a teen piano 14 p.m. dad it was I
think it was over what a hundred tons
120 between 120 and 140 tons they ended
up taking it took uh Langley took a
Model T and he had he took it apart and
assembled it in the basement and tried
to make an electrical generator out of
it yeah because like we said their
electricity in but yeah cuz they've been
on but they tried to repossess the place
and they thought that the the other
brother had died well no what they came
in they actually bashed their way in and
they were gonna repossess it because the
brothers hadn't paid the mortgage dinner
they weren't paying property taxes and
they argued that they shouldn't have to
okay because well we don't make any
money so we shouldn't have to pay taxes
even though they had [ __ ] loads of money
right because when the cops busted in
there the first time and through some of
their [ __ ] out on the street and said
hey you guys haven't you know paid the
mortgage we're kicking you out
Langly wrote a check for the whole
remaining amount yes a paid of the
mortgage say paid it off in one go and
that was actually I'm not sure I have to
look and see what I mean it was a lot of
money
it was act then it was like over a
million well it was no it was seventy
five hundred dollars which was I thought
in adjusted and adjusted terms it was
like close to a million dollars no this
was just was what was remaining hope
this was remaining on the mortgage oh
$6,700 so the equivalent of that is
about a hundred grand about a hundred
grand okay so he basically wrote a check
for a hundred grand and said get the
[ __ ] out right and uh so they did for a
while now they demanded to see his
brother remember the cop had to climb
all the way down through the tolls it
took him a half hour yeah to get there
yeah see two team on to confirm that the
other brother was alive because Langley
was very protective of home right
and remember he was totally paralyzed he
said in India to tell us how that went
down wouldn't well he just kind of sat
in this nest yeah and actually I don't I
don't actually know if he would let the
cops cuz he would not let anyone see him
no the cops armour remember he uh I read
that the cops actually saw him and he
was sitting upright with wild hair and
was filthy oh yeah looked up poorly
nourished like malnourished and he spoke
in perfect English that he was fine and
that I don't remember exactly what he
told him but uh had had to do it settle
in the mortgage of any but that he
wasn't there's blinding and it was
paralyzing that he was fine and he was
happy where he was yeah so they no crime
is being committed so they had to say
they couldn't right they couldn't do
anything about it and went on four years
later everybody wondered what the hell
was going on inside that mountain of
junk that they were in yeah because
there was pretty much like I said they
didn't know electricity no gas no phone
no nothing all they had a crystal radio
that Langley built that was about it but
they didn't talk to anyone and they you
know we couldn't stand up anywhere in
anything no you had to crawl through
tunnels and like we would close I guess
you could say like little close little
trap doors behind him with his foot and
pull things in there was no way into the
brownstone if you opened any doors or if
you opened any windows or broke anything
it was just you'd have to go through 30
or 40 feet yeah of junk and even the
windows they said that even the windows
in the basement that were broken like
his kids had broken them they still had
iron bars over them yeah so you still
couldn't get in that way and it wasn't
like you'd see on hoarders where just
random piles of [ __ ] this is all neatly
stacked and bundled pieces of chalk
there look that's making big bricks
that's another sad thing too is that a
lot of the stuff like obviously not a
lot of stuff but a good percentage of
the stuff was newspapers and Langley was
saving them because he thought that
Homer was going to get his sight back
and he would want to read all these
papers well and and it's this is what
and this is actually kind of sad this
made me kind of sad because obviously
these two were nuts yeah now Langley
thought that he
could cure homers blindness yeah by
giving him a special diet
it was oranges women 100 oranges a week
yeah black bread and peanut butter yeah
that was the diet and he said that he
didn't want to take homer to the doctor
because their dad had been a doctor and
they all about medicine and they did not
trust doctors they thought well they're
gonna cut homers optic nerve and then
he'll never get his sight yeah why would
they why did they think they would cut
the optic nerve I'm not entirely sure
why they thought that was there
something that they did back in the 30s
and the 40s about cutting people's optic
nerves
I don't know cuz everything all line ly
said because Langley actually was
interviewed by reporters like for a few
times and um he said we know all about
medicine cuz our dad was a doctor and
I'm just gonna treat him myself
and it'll all be fine and his vision
will come back and he will want to read
all these newspapers and there was like
decades of newspapers yeah and that
could that actually made me kind of sad
how could you read decades were the
newspapers right if I would even want to
yeah and spoiler alert he never did get
his sight back no no of course now yeah
this might as well jump to what happened
he did show up he did show up to court a
couple of times he showed up number in
1800s clothes yeah of course yeah he was
like cortisol shabby-looking yeah but he
was very articulate and he spoke very
you know spoke like an upper-class you
know a man would have what ended up
happening as you can probably predict is
that a anonymous tipster called the
police and said that they there was a
dead body smell yeah coming from the
house now the police were obviously
pretty used to going out there by now
because they're always kind of
complaints and other kind of [ __ ] they
were always doing it could because
another thing we didn't mention is
Langley was forever making complaints
about neighbors and about kids hanging
around his house of people coming around
his house I think one time when the cops
came there was like a thousand people in
the street like Curie's like wanting to
get a glimpse inside because they heard
all these weird things about them
because they were so eccentric so so
they called their bad dead bodies mouth
so the cops try to bust into the house
and obviously you know they couldn't
really get in there it's just a wall
junk so basically they had to start just
pulling [ __ ] out of the house and then
throwing it in the road they had to cut
in through the roof yeah I'm a very top
floor on the fourth floor remember they
there's photos photographs of them with
fire yes I'm not sure if that was the
first time because they went in twice
twice cuz what ended up happening was
now I think the first time so they went
in and they found Homer in his nest yeah
and he was dead and he had been dead
no he'd only been dead for 10 hours and
hours okay he was dead for 10 hours
he was sitting upright in his nest with
his head on his knees they thought he
had died of cardiac arrest and possibly
starvation yeah okay so they couldn't
find Langley anywhere yeah they said
think they thought that he had that you
know the brother had died and he had
taken off so they actually they had a
cop there at the house after they took
homers body out they had a cop there at
the house to wait for Langley to come
home and he never came home so they
thought well he must have just take it
off right and also no one they thought
he was one that called the cops yeah but
but it wasn't them I mean they don't
know exactly who it was cuz they gave us
a burglar it might have been her
honestly that's a bad thing but um or it
might have just been a neighbor that
didn't want they said they couldn't
smell anything
we'll see well I'll get to that yeah
all right so I was until later so
because they thought that Langley had
run they did a manhunt nine states
because there were you know obviously
there were people saying hey I saw I'm
here and I saw him there
so they never found him and then homers
funeral came and Langley didn't show up
and then they started to get suspicious
and actually at this point they were
thinking of the house was unsafe so they
thought well maybe we should look at the
house maybe Langley's dead in there
maybe that's what the dead body smell
was they had to empty the damn house and
they had to empty the whole has fought
like I said it's a four-story brownstone
I have pictures of it it's gone now but
um you know there's pictures of it it's
a huge huge house a huge mansion pretty
much yeah was imagined and so they go in
there and they start just pulling [ __ ]
out
19 tons of stuff just on the ground
floor they were thrown stuff out the
windows they were just throwing stuff
out the windows just throwing it all in
the street there's there's pictures or
pictures from the time for this was 1947
I believe pictures from the time of just
just garbage and junk yeah this was kind
of a like atmosphere because everyone
get everybody came and I think I
actually have found a picture of like
just all this huge crowd like the house
watching him throw everything out so
finally they it took out now this was a
week after they took homers body out
yeah like I said Homer they found
immediately I'm sitting up and it's
nothing his nest you know they knew
where his nest was right so you know a
week later like I said they hadn't found
Langley said they said well maybe he's
dead in the house so they start digging
all the [ __ ] out and they're I believe
if some sources say second floor some
say third floor but they say they
started taking all the [ __ ] out and they
see a foot yeah and the foot had been
partially gnawed by rats
yeah and so they start moving the [ __ ]
and obviously Langley had been dead and
he was right near the brother wedding 10
feet away and feet away what had
happened and this is this is the saddest
part of all that's hard that's sad when
you find the body and you didn't know
that the other body was away so in send
it away because it was down Anna tangley
was crawling through a two-foot tunnel
that was booby-trapped he was bringing
food to his brother they assumed yeah
and it collapsed crushed him and crushed
him yeah and he had been in there
and then his brother obviously starved
to death couldn't move or see star
started a third or you know died of
thirst or died of thirst one of those
that he was in there for a long time
knowing that his dead brother was right
next to him in the dipper here's what
this kind of creeps me out like what if
what if Langley was in the tunnel and
then all the [ __ ] fell on him it was
like a big suitcase and a bunch of metal
bread boxes and like ah it was a trap
right and he accidentally tripped it and
uh and so here's what I wondering like
did it squish him outright or no they
said he suffocated oh my god so that
means he could probably talk to his
brother and go
bro you re yeah I'm squashed yeah oh
that is so nasty yeah and then the rats
ate him and then the rats ate my
problems right next to him oh it's awful
it's awful
yeah pretty bad it's an awful story yeah
and so basic yeah poor bastard I'm just
it makes me I know it was a long time
ago but it's like ah ah yeah we got a
photograph of the eat for the that of
the devour body to the body that was
eating did you find that if yeah there I
got it oh okay you know you have to set
me cop [ __ ] they're looking in there any
nut body so alright so uh so here's the
thing so obviously after that they're
both dead the house was clearly it was
garb not fit to live in it was Japan
packed with so much debris for so long
just structurally unsound
specially I said and yeah so they like I
said they ended up taking about a
hundred hundred twenty hundred thirty
tons Tom funds Tomczyk stuff out of this
four-story mansion now there's a limit
once been there's a list of what was in
there there was like seven pianos it was
fourteen fourteen things for Odeon
pianos do you have that list um there's
actually there's one on Wikipedia it
doesn't say everything that was in there
but they said a lot of the stuff was
from their father's medical practice
there was a lot of medical you know
tools and machines or whatnot is
ridiculous
yeah baby carriages a doll carriage
rusted bicycles old food potato peelers
a gun collection glass chandeliers
bowling balls camera equipment the
folding top of a horse-drawn carriage
yeah car like you do a car sawhorse
three dressmaking dummies portraits
photos of pin-up girls from the early
1900s
yeah their mothers hope chests it was
ridiculous yeah just totally the
photographs those absolutely ridiculous
pickled human organs in jars yeah yeah
that's right it ate live cats oh that's
right least it was a dead cat forgot to
I've seen hoarders on TLC and they go
ahead cats and remember the one that
kept all the dead cats in
refrigerator oh yeah there was like dead
cat juice oh that's late I know it's
like making me kind of nauseous Chuck
without the woman has saved all her own
feces there was more than one of them
yeah yeah a whole bag my kids just like
throat couldn't you just throw it out
the window or something like this Bob
why would you just throw it in the
corner yeah anyway good so but another
thing they found like other than all
this like junk and garbage they also
found 34 bank pass books and that had a
total of three thousand nineteen
forty-seven dollars which is about 36
grand today now they took all the stuff
out of the house
they said eighty ninety percent of it
worthless junk garbage um the items that
they did save they auctioned off two
thousand dollars that's it and but
however the cumulative estate of the
Collier brothers when they died 19:47
money $91,000 damn over a million bucks
well today's money so they did have
money yeah they weren't poor they could
have moved away they could have moved it
just hoarder mentality nuts crazy and
that's what's the saddest thing about
this and every time we say this every
time well it's one of the things every
time we watch hoarders on TLC I look I
know it's a mental illness yeah my
grandfather had it so I'm familiar but
not not as bad as the collar brothers at
least you could still walk through the
house there was a path I'm just saying
but uh it's weird how like dude hoarders
because there's kind of a difference
between actually hoarding is more common
at dudes it is and women even though TLC
it's mostly women on the show they
actually because I think that's the
dudes are too ashamed to be on TV that's
probably why but it's actually more
common in men it's a you know it's a
spin-off of OCD it's similar kind of
illness every time we watch that show
it's like I see the house I'm just like
you know what burn it down start over
yeah I know that's not gonna help them I
know it's not gonna help them let's do
it again they'll just do it again
newswoman I got too many stuff too many
too much stuff too many stuff too many
too many stuff yeah probably time for a
break she was so cute though alright so
yeah we can talk a little bit more about
this when we get back and then we'll
talk about it so we're going to take a
break since we're coming up to the half
an hour mark and we will be right back I
would like to take a second and thank
subculture corsets in clothing for
sponsoring project I radio and my show
while listening to my podcast please
take a second and visit their website at
www.att.com/biz go fix steampunk and pin
up clothing shoes and accessories again
their website is subculture corsets calm
or if you're in the Jacksonville Florida
area stop by their store in The Avenues
Mall and if you like to save money use
the discount code 13 o'clock when
checking out and save 10% off your
entire order by the way if you're a
curvy girl subculture do not forget
about you they carry size 4 to 4 X and
guys they have men's clothing and shoes
as well so go shop at subculture corsets
calm now and use the discount code 13
o'clock for a 10% discount all right now
you ever talk about the Colliers so
we're talking about the Collier brothers
so after they died after they died since
they're you know since their estate was
over a million dollars so then they had
people crawling out of the Woodworks and
they were related oh yeah I forgot about
that more yeah which you know a bunch of
people saying that they were distant
relatives
vultures yeah but um actually when it
all shook down the final estate was
split between 23 people yeah because you
know I guess they figured out who was
related to them and who wasn't
yeah and they had one woman that she she
had tried to collect on several estates
remember her yeah that's right I got
wind you forgot who it was oh yeah right
here Ella Davis Ella Davis she was from
Pittsburgh and she said she was their
long-lost sister but she couldn't
produce a birth certificate and they
also found out that she had also claimed
to be the widow of some other wealthy
reclusive dude a few years ago so they
were like Yammer on - you made a little
literal grave digger yeah
and now now the the
I that she'd gold-digger but a great day
a great day well yeah cuz I was gonna
say that the first guy the other wealthy
recluse she said was the widow was found
murdered uh in third 30s damn she's
probably dead now it's already so all
these people involved all these people
are dead yeah yeah so the lasting legacy
of these poor guys I mean you know I get
eaten by rats next to your bra yeah yeah
don't get squished by your own booby
traps yeah and so for a long time I
don't know about now because I'm not
from New York but for a long time
mothers in New York if their kids made a
mess or something or if their kid's room
was a mess it's a regular Collyer
brothers in here they would say and like
I said it's uh it's also still a
firefighting term that might have been
in other nations first yeah up close and
personal examination or behavior yeah
and I imagine in the 40s they wouldn't
know they wouldn't have known that
wouldn't a been a common what the deal
with it was right I mean now they know
yeah it's a disorder on the OCD spectrum
well the cops are mystified yeah yeah I
imagine they had probably never seen
write or anything to that extent I mean
because it was so large yeah the house
was so large you see when you see the
photos it's it's unbelievable it's
unbelievable you could put that much
stuff and in a brownstone well and this
is another thing that every time we
watch hoarders when it was a bit solid
it was solid yeah it was solid sounds a
solid block of stuff just solid stuff
yeah and every time we watch boarders I
always think this one how do they get
all that [ __ ] in there not expect the
[ __ ] floor to collapse which it does
sometimes - where are they getting the
money to buy all that stuff these guys I
don't duh mean yeah these guys pick
stuff out of garbage and they had money
but sometimes like on hoarders you see
kind of these lower-middle-class kind of
people you know they're dumpster diving
yeah what sometimes don't even jobs and
it's like well yeah but like what about
the ones that like to go or no I'm gonna
go on a shopping spree and they go buy
all these clothes it's like with one
it yeah what I just like I don't god
it's like I feel guilty about going and
having to buy like bottle of shampoo
like oh my god that's four dollars I
could have used that for something out
you know what I mean it's like hey so I
can't imagine just like going to a store
and just like buying like tons of the
[ __ ] that you don't mean ever need and
then never use it again they keep it in
the bag a lot of times yeah they never
even look at it they probably forget
it's in there yeah so what's the next
one
well the next set of brothers alright so
the next set of are this is kind of
related that's why I wanted to put them
on the same thing there's a
gynaecologist tie-in and also a weird
brother kind of thing and also a little
bit of boarding at the end yeah I don't
know this one I don't know about this
piece oh okay so this story probably a
little less known than the Collyer
brothers however if you're a fan of
David Cronenberg he made a movie in 1988
called dead ringer some of you have
probably seen it and what you may not
know is that Dead Ringers was based on
two real guys and the movie is I mean as
weird as the movie is you know if you
haven't seen it Jeremy Irons and he
plays twin Gynaecologists who have this
horrible like downward spiral of mental
illness and drug abuse and end up dying
in this creepy psychosexual kind of
weird thing they have going on and
actually I had thought that the movie
was kind of loosely based on two real
guys but no it's actually pretty close
so these guys were the Marcus brothers
Stewart and Cyril they look like Ted
Cruz they'd be a long cruise yeah both
of their they look like twins no you're
Ted Cruz is the Zodiac boy Ted Ted Cruz
looks a little bit like grandpa monster
but yeah I guess you guys don't I can
see that as guys don't they look like a
young Ted Cruz without the monster Ness
and without the butthole mouth yeah
there's like a good-looking Ted Cruz if
you could imagine that I don't know
Brian but um so these two were actually
twin brothers um Cyril and Stuart like I
said look like Ted Cruz not the Zodiac
killer okay they were
also quite prominent citizens okay I
believe they went to Cornell all right
and they were both gynecologists okay
and well-regarded gynecologist
obstetricians also they worked at they
did fertility treatments and evidently
were quote unquote miracle workers okay
with women's fertility now they a lot a
lot of other doctors who knew them said
they were kind of dicks good you know
which a lot of doctors are I guess
especially hotshot ones noting say why
the did dicks they said they were very
arrogant they weren't very good at
taking criticism or of that type of
thing
dick like behavior all right they um
were they had kind of a really weird
like kind of close relationship they
went to the same medical school they
shared cadavers in anatomy class and
they lived in the same dorm in their
college and all this other stuff now I
don't think well they were twins yeah
okay so they had that weird like 20
thing going on now I don't think not
like the Collier brothers I don't think
they lived together okay mmm it first
all right one of them married now the
other one I don't think he ever did not
one of them married and divorced okay
well well bye range what will happen
what was strange about them well
evidently even from before what ended up
happening to them there were rumors that
they were not right
there's a book but called the professor
in the prostitute by Linda Wolfe and it
has like a lot of kind of weird true
crime stories in it and the woman who
wrote the book actually a Stewart was
her doctor briefly and she said that she
saw him a couple times and then the
third time the third visit she was there
he started to like flip out on her like
he she said he got angry about something
she didn't know what she started
screaming and like going into this wacky
rage and everything like that and
finally I mean her husband was with her
so it was fertility and you know the
husband's like this get the [ __ ] out of
here cuz this guy's clearly off his
rocker
so they exhibited
one of the middle-east exhibited
nurdrage yes well what happened word
rage
well what ended up happening uh they
were actually even though I think one of
them got are addicted to barbiturates
okay and then the other one kind of
followed along the same path like I
don't think the firt the other one was
addicted at first but then he kind of
got into it so their their 40s by this
time yeah all right and so they they
started [ __ ] up at work all right
um one of them I think like pulled masks
off their patients they threw [ __ ] at
them right um they just started acting
like I'm gonna tears acting a fool now
just like in the in the David Cronenberg
movie one of them when one of them was
indisposed the other one would take its
place because they looked so much alike
and no one could tell the difference
right um that went on for a little while
until the you know the up to then still
kind of saying twin also descended into
barbiturate okay addiction and also
started acting like a tool all the time
so I think they were both I'm not sure
if they were both fired but they were
both for sure reprimanded and uh it's
what ended up happening to them was like
I said they kind of went on this
downward spiral oh how was it don't work
on brush dude we're only at 35 minutes
ah I can talk all I want you oh no what
happened quit rushing me I want to know
what happened well if you saw the movie
probably you probably kind of know yeah
I didn't see that now once again what
happened obviously what happened what
ended up happening they're not entirely
sure how they died well they know how
one of them died not so much the other
one both of them were found in Cyril's
apartment okay one of them was draped
over a twin bed in one bedroom the other
one was lying on a twin bed in the other
bedroom all right the apartment was
totally trashed okay
garbage ever
we're all right smelled like I don't
know how long they had been in like
holed up in there but there was just
like garbage everywhere everything was
right there was a chair in the living
room like an armchair that was full of
poop there may have been pooping in the
chair they've been [ __ ] in the chair
they have been [ __ ] you got a
picture of this you got photos of this I
don't know there might be one I'll have
a look I don't want to see a picture I
want to see I want to see how [ __ ] up
this apart there's a dinner house it's
an apartment it was him it was in
Manhattan
alright they're both dead the but ones
in one bed ones in the other bed they
had the apartment trash they were
[ __ ] and that [ __ ] they were
[ __ ] in the chair and the chair up
front and when they did the autopsy now
they thought initially Oh barbiturate
overdose nope yeah uh barbiturate
withdrawal yeah maybe
okay they said one of them Cyril I
believe when they did the toxicology or
whatever it's like they found traces in
there uh-huh
because apparently they'd been trying to
kick the barbiturates and were on
dilantin or whatever or Nembutal or
whatever the drug is that they used to
get you off of that but they only found
trace amounts of it okay the other one
they didn't find [ __ ] all right
so they're not real sure how the other
one died and now Stewart I think was the
one that died second but he had actually
people had seen him leaving the house
after Cyril was dead so they're not
really sure he must have killed zero
that's what I'm wondering yeah so
they're not I don't know if anyone ever
actually really suggested that but
obviously Cyril died first from the
autopsy he didn't tell anybody and he
didn't tell anybody and he left the
house to go run an errand or something
it then he went back to this house it
was like stinking with trash and poop
and everything how rotten was Cyril when
they found him not very I don't think
they died on the same time yeah I don't
think it was that far apart okay so they
don't know if it was like murder or it
was like a suicide pact try suicide one
maybe dyed yellow and killed himself
yeah because he
and he killed one maybe he killed the
his twin and then he killed himself
yes I'm like that or the twin died on
his own from what syrup because
apparently like I said I don't know I'm
not a barbiturate addict but apparently
trying to withdraw from barbiturates is
like worse than the addiction it was
like that'll kill you so they don't know
if Cyril just died of that and then
Stewart couldn't live without the
brother right although like why why was
he like wandering I don't know I don't
know why he was walk around the street
and didn't tell anybody that he was dead
but um you know all that kind of [ __ ]
damn it might be time for a break yeah
we can take cuz now we're doing two
breaks sorry guys yeah I gotta do two
bricks and the second break is myself
and my self indulgent break they were
gonna break okay so we're gonna break
for another few seconds and then we will
be back
there's harrows real and imaginary and I
write about them all paranormal
nonfiction or fiction Rossdale the
Mammoth Mountain culture associated
monster Red Menace the patina Brucella
weather go to WWJD AFRICOM or search
Amazon for the Jenny Ashford author page
all right we're back so hoarders and
weird brothers yeah weird hoarder
brothers I don't know I just think that
was probably uh one died and you haven't
committed suicide that's what I think
happened I don't think of it I don't
think there was a murder there's no sign
of murder than her probably probably not
maybe it was like a suicide the one saw
that the other was that now and that's
how Cronenberg played it in his movie
like one of them died of overdose and
then the other one the other one killed
himself with one of the weird
gynecological tools they invented to
work on mutant women because it's
Cronenberg oh my god like to see that
apartment was there anything unusual
that you know about the apartment of the
other than other than I just being
totally garbage truck and here's here's
something that bothers about this case
and about the Collier brother's case
these guys were not poor they were not
indigent they were not they had a bunch
of money they had a bunch of money they
had jobs they didn't care though they
were respected they'd [ __ ] in a chair
and Harvey I mean no it's like it's like
think of all the people whose lives are
like super shitty or you don't have much
money or who are like trying to have to
work three jobs and they're not like and
it's like you don't see them doing that
kind of stuff what would make what would
flip that switch in your brain not to go
from not giving a [ __ ] I guess I guess
to go from like I'm a successful doctor
I have money blah blah I'm [ __ ] in a
chair well you just got I guess you just
kind of take it for granted when you
have went when you're a doctor you have
all that money you just go well it's
normal and it's not making me happy so
[ __ ] it
I'm gonna [ __ ] in a chair like you do
like you do [ __ ] a chair right now I'm
mad I'm gonna go [ __ ] at you can't tell
you what goes to these people's minds
I mean yawns they gotta be mentally ill
so I mean the Collyer brothers clearly
then you have two two brothers they're
both going crazy and they're already
twins so I'd imagine the crazy can get
pretty crazy yeah cuz they're egging
each other on right yeah
and twins are so similar like that
there's got to be
I'm kind of weird like synergy going on
with kind of like hey I'm not sure
that's why cuz my [ __ ] they just said
you know [ __ ] the world [ __ ] it yeah
give me that chair my shitty we can't
get past that you can't get that I want
to see a photo I want to see how bad it
is just like well the woman that wrote
that book that I mentioned before that
had been his patient briefly she said
that when she was researching the book
she went to talk to the cop that
investigated the case and she said that
the cop had a blow-up of the [ __ ] chair
yeah like on the back of the door like
cuz they thought it was funny cuz
they're likely these [ __ ] doctors may
not shut in a chair I'm gonna blow up
this picture I have a picture of an
armchair full of [ __ ] on the back of my
office wonder if they sat in the [ __ ] to
take a [ __ ] well you would have to
because it was more than one [ __ ] yeah
it's more than one [ __ ] they didn't
throw their ass over the over the
armchair Oh me oh yeah
maybe they threw the ass you're thinking
a lot about this second about how to eat
[ __ ] [ __ ] maybe thank you
maybe they didn't actually sit in the
chair they shove their hats over the arm
I didn't even think then I'm not I'm not
why not just use the toilet I'm not a
cherish I just use the toilet that's
what I mean they got weathered in there
right yeah that was another thing that
was another thing now is Toyota's prize
spotless on flushed ha ha
whoopee gives way Warner in it
everything tidy Bowl man you know we'll
see the thing is the thing is about I
know it's so gross what sorry when it's
office such a gross direction well I'm
get about to get grosser because like I
said that show we saw on hoarders that
big fat woman that was just throwing
bags of [ __ ] in the in the back bathroom
now
she was not flushing the toilet because
the toilet was broken and there was no
water the water been turned off because
she got in pain that's why I brought
this up right bet you that water was
blue and special Indian they had a
perfectly good bathroom and I'm sure it
was right there it was a Manhattan
apartment it was probably as big as a
[ __ ] closet
right yeah you know what I mean so it's
like the bathrooms right there you just
poop in a chair on our Saturday juice
but you know hoarding man I don't know
so what happened with the case today did
they ever find out how they died or do
they still don't know like I said they
think the first one that died was
probably barbiturate withdrawal the
second one they don't know really they
said maybe it was that but the
toxicology didn't show anything of that
no one no one was accused of anything no
charges or not no not as far as I know
that's what kind of makes it mystifying
it's like what any [ __ ] died of a
broken heart I don't know something kiss
his beloved [ __ ] brothers dead plus
I don't know if they everyone said there
were tickets I'm just saying just kind
of weird but I'm a hoarding man I don't
know hoarding yeah I can't get past that
either cause like I said it frustrates
me it's very frustrating him like I said
I have I had he's dead now
but I had a relative who was a hoarder
and a similar kind of thing happened he
had when um his wife left him in the 70s
up to then him big house bigs with like
a really cool spooky house and when his
wife left him in the 70s he went and he
was kind of the same as the Collier
brothers he was kind of one of those
weird genius who's inventing stuff and
yeah he had all these patents and stuff
he's really really smart he taught me to
play chess when I was little and then
after she left the house just started
accumulating yeah and it was a lot of
the same stuff that the collars cuz guns
cameras that kind of stuff well these
are these doctors probably weren't
hoarders though they were just went nuts
they were [ __ ] they just went nuts yeah
it looks like a horror situation when
they found them just because they had
been in there for a while like it was
stuffing yeah and they weren't throwing
anything away one it was mostly garbage
they're probably in there dying and play
probably was water to die again yeah
they were very cold they weren't very
old they price gave up but I don't know
for some reason it's like it's kind of
sad it's also like I said I I don't know
I find it sad every time every time we
watch hoarders I just kid I get really
impatient that like just clean it up
clean it up and I hate cleaning I know
but I never I'm not gonna get it let it
go like that I'm not gonna get like like
I said is I had a family member that was
a hoarder and it was you you just had a
[ __ ] path through the house and
whatnot I played I think that's pretty
much all week
about this lingo and wrap it up okay we
did we did the two breaks already right
yeah
I don't even remember that's how to
that's how like [ __ ] freaked out on
by the [ __ ] here we're still thick
that's what I'm gonna use as that as the
picture for this episode if an eye won't
realize we're pretty bad swear I won't
okay uh so yeah we're gonna wrap it up
yeah yeah but if there's not much more
we can say about that yeah just--we're
does but if you're on the pot if you're
on the podcast you didn't see the photos
that we posted then you can go check out
the call your brother's photos they're
just a trip yeah there were a bunch of
them they took a [ __ ] ton of photos back
and there's actually still um the cops
took a bunch if you google it there's
actually a lot of newspaper articles
from 1947 when they found their bodies
and stuff great that you can read all
yet it is very big on there hopefully we
can find some photos from the other one
yeah there's a few not very many but I'm
gonna look for some work up for the
video all right all right so um
hopefully you liked this episode six and
if you like the show please subscribe I
will put up a little clicky button on
the YouTube show and also like us on
Facebook and follow us on Twitter and
all of that you know you were to have
another guests into we're gonna bring
another guest on yeah we're gonna have
food shop it'll be a secret though that
last guest head on aggragate oak was
real good when we had uh we had a lot of
history that was a fun shot wasn't it
that was a fun show
we're gonna have to do it we're never
gonna guess we're gonna have to get a
good good guest this coming month all
right already
and that'll do it for a thirteen o'clock
see you next week
you
[Music]